- HEY, 40s!
- YEAH.
WHOO!
- YOU KNOW,
GRAMPS WOULD'VE BEEN PROUD.
YOU SAVED
THIS FINE FAMILY.
- THANKS FOR LETTING ME
BE THE HERO,
AND FOR NOT ONE-UPPING ME, DAD.
- YEAH, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S ONE OTHER TINY THING
I SHOULD TELL YOU
BEFORE I GET DRUNKER
THAN YOU EVER COULD.
- MM?
- I'M NOT ACTUALLY YOUR FATHER.
- WHAT?
- SON,
I'M YOUR BROTHER, BRO.
DAD TOOK OFF,
AND ME AND MOM FIGURED
THE MOST LOGICAL THING TO DO
WOULD BE TO LIE
TO YOUR FACE FOREVER.
- THAT'S COOL.
- YEAH?
- 'CAUSE YOU WERE
A HORRIBLE DAD.
- YEAH.
- YOU'D PROBABLY MAKE
AN AWESOME BROTHER.
YOU LIED TO ME
MY WHOLE LIFE!
THAT'S HILARIOUS.
- YEAH!
both: YEAH!
- ADAM, WHAT'S UP, DUDE?
I'M A KNIGHT.
HOW'S--HOW'S THIS ALL GOING?
- I COULD'VE KILLED MYSELF.
IT WAS REALLY DANGEROUS.
SO IT WAS AWESOME.
HEY, I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
MY BROTHER, DAD.
- WHAT?
- I BELIEVE THIS MAKES US EVEN.
- UH, I BELIEVE I ASKED YOU
FOR A LIFETIME SUBSCRIPTION
TO PIZZA, SO...
- WELL, THEN
I WILL JUST GO AHEAD
AND TAKE THIS TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
- NO, NO, WE'RE COOL.
WE'RE GOOD.
WE'RE EVEN.
- OKAY?
HEY, GUYS.
I JUST WANTED TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT I GET IT.
I TOTALLY GET IT
ABOUT THE DEMAMPS.
THEY DO EVERYTHING JUST A LITTLE
DIFFERENT, AND SO DID GRAMPS,
I'M SURE YOU KNOW--
THE SCULPTURES.
YOU HAVEN'T SEE--
HAVE YOU SEEN THE SCULPTURES?
YEAH, BECAUSE
I HAD THEM DESTROYED.
IT'S VERY DARK STUFF,
EXTREMELY DISTURBING.
ANYHOO, I GUESS IT'S ABOUT TIME
TO, YOU KNOW,
GET THIS BITCH-ASS PARTY
STARTED!
- OH, YES.
- WHOA.